mais la meinau et messieurs bonjour je
serais presque tenté de vous dire bonnes
vacances puisque quelques millions
d'entre vous seront dès ce soir
effectivement en congé en effet cette
année le calendrier était bien fait car
il vous suffira de passer le pont celui
du 14 juillet pour emprunter plus tôt
que prévu la route des vacances
cela dit et bien pour la route ne partez
pas tous cette nuit à 4 heures du matin
pour ne pas faire comme tout le monde et
encore une fois soyez prudents et penser
à la limitation de vitesse pour ce par
ailleurs qui voyagent par avion et bien
une bonne nouvelle à orly ce matin des
manutentionnaires d'air france les
bagagistes ont repris leur travail le
trafic est donc redevenue normale et
vous arriverez et vous partirez à leurs
prêts cela dit votre seconde
préoccupation je suppose en cette
période de vacances concerne bien
évidemment le temps et nous avons fait
appel une fois de plus à notre voisin
monsieur météo
monsieur la rivière qui va sans doute
nous donner les prévisions rhône ont pas
pour très très longtemps pour un mois ou
pour un mois et demi mais tout
simplement et plus prosaïquement pour ce
week-end est tendue et pour les premiers
jours de ce week-end
commençons par aujourd'hui par cet après
midi oui les choses s'annoncent bien
aujourd'hui en sorte que vous le voyez
l'air frais nous avons supporté ces
derniers jours s'en va au delà de la
scandinavie et que le soleil va être
général sur la france aujourd'hui mais
nous ne sommes jamais heureux d'annoncer
des mauvaises choses mais c'est quand
même le cas vous voyez que plus au large
sur l'atlantique
des pluies sont en train d'arriver que
nous avons d'ailleurs détectés grâce aux
observations du navire méthodique
stationnaire qui est au point qu'à en
permanence voici le point qu'a donc
toute cette formation nuageuse va se
diriger maintenant sourire la face mais
en laissant de côté quand même je crois
le mini oui et de toute façon
voyez elle est accompagnée d'air chaud
c'est une bonne nouvelle quand même la
wii en fait donc peu aujourd'hui
beau temps partout avec des températures
de l'ordre de 20 degrés près de la
manche 24 à 25 sur le reste de la france
et près de la méditerranée 30 demain
oh alors demain on se garde bien sûr la
zone depuis arrive et prend un caractère
orageux en traversant la france les
régions les plus favorisés sont celles
qui seront situés au sud d'une ligne
approximative bordeaux balle là il fera
très beau avec des températures de
l'ordre de 30 ou même plus
l'après-midi alors sur le nord de la
france donc la zone depuis arrive il est
probable qu'elle sera dès la nuit dans
l'ouest et au cours de la journée elle
traversera donc le bassin parisien pour
sept ans jusqu'à la belgique et prendre
un caractère orageux prenez les chez
nous quand même des éclaircies oui bah
voyait les éclaircies reviennent assez
rapidement derrière en bretagne au cours
de la journée les températures donc
comme je vous le disais sont normales
pour le mois de juillet 26 à 27 à
l'avant des orages avec des baisses dans
les orale bien sûr 22 degrés ou un peu
plus dans l'eau elle est comme neuve on
dit 32 degrés environ dans le bassin
médical de celle arrivée à derrière ces
nuages enfin du moins à cette ligne je
vois quand même qu'il ya du ciel bleu à
gauche la de cette photo est ce que le
beau temps va revenir alors pour
précisément lundi et mardi prochain est
ce qu'on pourra danser le 14 juillet se
fait dixons les et quatre jours qui
viennent nous attendons la persistance
de ce temps chaud donc c'est pas
désagréable d'un certain point de vue
mais aussi orageux en tout cas sur le
nord de la france il est probable que le
beau temps du midi va remonter jusqu'à
la loire et peut-être même un peu plus
au cours du week-end bien on pourra donc
danser la nuit du 14 juillet sous les
lampions sans prendre un parapluie quand
même danse et l'orge et nous vous posons
être qu'un normal ce produit jusque là
cela se peut pas vous donner le minutage
désormais je n'ose vous poser la
question mais je la pose quand même pour
ceux maintenant qu'ils partent en
vacances essayez quand même de dire on
pour le mois de juillet ce que ce mois
de juillet 14 juillet-15 août plutôt
sera un mois épouvantable une manière
générale où est ce que ce sera moi comme
les autres fait de toute façon s'il
était épouvantable je voudrais jamais le
dire il ya quelque chose que ça ne se
vérifie pas et il vaut mieux leur avenir
avec optimisme
non ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on avait
annoncé pour le mois de juillet bien
qu'on ne va jamais le publier de manière
officielle des températures quand même
un peu plus élevé que la normale ça a
été un départ plutôt dans le sens
contraire
mais avec ce temps orageux qui vient on
peut espérer jusqu'à la fin du mois mais
on va rattraper le déficit qu'on a eu
dans les dix premiers jours et que donc
jusqu'à la fin du mois ce peut être bon
et bien c'est perez web c'était un
souhait que vous êtes beaucoup à
formuler en ce moment j'espère donc que
cette prédiction se réalisera merci
monsieur j ai maintenant maintenant pour
ceux qui restent avec nous pendant ces
vacances 14 juillet-15 août et bien à
paris à paris ou dans les grandes villes
va commencer cette période de calme de
stationnement facile sans problème c'est
très bien mais attention car beaucoup de
ce torse fermeront chez les commerçants
devant les banques certains services
publiques tourneront plus lentement et
nous aurons déjà pour ce week-end un
avant goût de ce que l'on appelle ce
désert abouti alors nous avons demandé à
france des sceaux peut faire le point
des gens de ce qui sera fermé pour ce
week end du 14 juillet
eh bien oui vous risquez de trouver la
plupart de vos commerçants fermée lundi
et mardi à l'exception des grands
magasins qui resteront ouverts lundi
normalement
de même pour ceux qui auraient besoin
d'un service médical n'oubliez pas que
votre médecin a pu lui aussi mettre la
clé sous le paillasson
il est donc utile de noter par avance le
téléphone du commissariat le plus proche
qui vous indiquera quel son médecin et
pharmacie de garde
j'indique aussi que les bureaux des
caisses d'allocations familiales seront
fermés lundi et mardi
alors quant aux banques elles seront
fermées aux heures habituelles ce
vendredi pour ne rouvrir que mercredi
matin et enfin le lundi 13 juillet les
bureaux de poste seront ouverts dans les
conditions habituelles du samedi
la distribution du courrier à domicile
sera assurée le mardi 14 juillet les
bureaux seront fermés sauf dans les
permanences fonctionnant habituellement
le dimanche entre 8 et 11 heures
vous pourrez alors utiliser les
services téléphoniques étaient des
graphiques et retirer votre courrier à
la poste restante
et pour ce qu une visite au musée est
entré pendant ce week-end prolongé
sachez que seuls les musées nationaux de
versailles fontainebleau peau chantilly
et compiègne seront ouverts au public
il fonde le chantilly compiègne il ya
quand même une certaine façon de passer
le temps avec ses musées ouverts pour
ceux donc qui veulent un peu se détendre
et voir de fort belles choses les sports
maintenant et bien
avant-hier rappelez-vous il régnait
comme au stade de colombes
comme un avant-goût de 14 juillet de
fête nationale en effet c'était un peu
la fête de l'athlétisme français car
notre équipe menait devant celle des
états unis par cette victoire at hélas
hier soir les dieux du stade n'était pas
favorable d'une expression et en fin de
compte et bien les etats unis ont battu
la france par 117 points à 94 mais c'est
un résultat plus qu'honorable devant
l'une des meilleures équipes du monde et
vous savez que les français ont réalisé
des performances de très haute tenue
ils ont égalé certains records de france
personnel ou même d'ailleurs des records
de vente et les américains en fin de
compte hier soir s'ils ont gagné ont
quand même été forcé de sortir ce qu'on
appelle en termes d'athétisme le branche
claude mais dieu oui et si j'étais
america je serais revenu satisfait de
colomb hier soir ce fut en effet une
soirée américaine et six points d'avance
de l'équipe de france allait fondre
comme neige au soleil surtout après le
110 m haies les français sont en blanc
et les walcker ne laisseront aucune
chance à dru entre les deux il gagne en
13 secondes et 3/10 même temps pour
voile caire drulhe 13 secondes cinq
dixièmes mais avant deux-trois médical
ne lui permet pas d'améliorer son record
de france au javelot collins gagne avec
79 m 38
le 400 m une des plus belles courses de
la soirée
colette devant vous n'allez derrière lui
smith quand un départ très rapide il a
remonté tout son décalage sur jean
claude mallet il va même attaqué colette
carette est derrière mais on va très
vite devant
il semble à la sortie du virage que
jean-claude nallet va attaquer colette
mais regardez bien dans un instant le
départ extraordinaire de l'américain
colette qui laisse sur place
jean claude mallet colette 44 secondes
neuf dixièmes smith 45 secondes
nallet 45 secondes quatre dixièmes
nouveau record de france
au 200 m le français en blanc sarthe
heures quand un départ foudroyant
il remonte tout son décalage sur corner
à l'entrée de la ligne droite il est en
tête mais c'est là maintenant que les
américains passent la vitesse supérieure
tourneur premier vingt secondes 6/10
vaughan 20 secondes 7/10 starter 20
secondes 8/10 au triple saut seule
victoire française hier soir firca 16
mètres 32
en 15 100 m 20 12 n'était pas remis des
fatigues de son 5000 m dufresne et le
borgne était donc nos représentants aux
12 100 mètres d'où venait de le voir les
deux américains attaquent dufresne
essaiera bien de résister mais il ne
pourra rien contre le finish de michael
et de van dyck 1er mickaël trois minutes
44 secondes trois dixièmes deuxième
verdict trois minutes 44 secondes 90e
quant à la dernière course le relais 4 x
400 m elle allait montrer tout l'écart
qu'il y à encore entre l'athlétisme
américain et l'athlétisme français tout
ce matin nous avons appris que serge
philippe k qui a gagné hier le concours
du triple saut qui et recordwoman de
france et champion de france de la
spécialité a été assez grièvement blessé
dans un accident de la circulation qui
est arrivé à 7 heures avenue du
président roosevelt à issy les
moulineaux pour une raison encore
inconnue sa voiture a heurté le mur d'un
pavillon firca a été transporté à
l'hôpital corentin celton nous ne
pouvons pas en dire davantage
nous espérons que son état de santé ne
sera pas très à venir si claude métier
l'actualité politique et sociale vous
vous en doutez prendre elle aussi son
régime de croisière
mais avant les vacances précisément dans
certains domaines on tente d'arriver à
des accords sur les salaires et sur
d'autres problèmes sociaux c'est ainsi
qu'hier soir un accord a été signé à la
ratp entre la direction et les syndicats
3 % d'augmentation à la rentrée droit
syndical renforcer et modernisation des
installations
ce matin par ailleurs vient d'être signé
l'accord sur la mensualisation dans
l'industrie métallurgique cet accord
intéresse 1 million 700 mille
travailleurs et un autre accord sera
également signé cet après-midi dans la
sidérurgie
après vos vacances si vous partez avant
le 16 juillet si vous restez vous
paierez votre gaz 5 % plus cher et
l'électricité vous sera facturée avec
une majoration de 3 courses
voilà pour les principales informations
en france dans ce domaine pour
l'étranger bien sachez tout d'abord qu'à
17 heures cet après-midi les irlandais
du nord sont eux aussi en vacances ou du
moins en compte on fait le pont en
irlande pour célébrer la victoire en
seize 190d ans j c'est-à-dire des
protestants contre les catholiques est
inutile de préciser que dans le climat
actuel on attend s'attend à de nouveaux
heurts entre les deux communautés
cent mille personnes sont déjà arrivées
à belfast et protestants pour la plupart
ces derniers vous savez prépare un
défilé monstre et de leur côté les
catholiques prévoit une sorte de contre
des filets à 17 heures cet après-midi ce
ne sera pas l'heure du thé du whisky
irlandais dans les pubs mais celui de la
bière ce sera donc l'heure de la bière
et du scotch et 7000 soldats
britanniques
sont venus en renfort pour tenter de
canaliser ce défilé est pour tenter de
mettre un peu d'ordre
parmi les esprits échauffés à partir de
ce soir en bref maintenant les autres
nouvelles internationales moyen-orient
c'est maintenant officiel
un accord vient d'être signé entre le
gouvernement jordanien et les commandos
palestiniens parmi des clauses les plus
importantes on peut retenir celle ci le
gouvernement garantit la liberté
d'action des commandos et leurs droits
de mobiliser le peuple à condition
qu'aucune atteinte ne soit porté à la
souveraineté de l'état jordan
moyen-orient toujours tel-aviv annonce
ce matin que 3021 ont été abattus par
rocket rr donc depuis des avions des
chasseurs dans le secteur nord du canal
de suez pour les acadiens de chinois cet
après midi le président nixon doit
rencontrer à washington monsieur tente
pour faire le point de la situation
d'indochine
monsieur temps d'hier a été quelque peu
conspué alors qu'il assistait à la
première séance de l'assemblée mondiale
de la jeunesse au chapitre maintenant de
l'information générale et pour revenir
en france il faut évoquer déjà et
malheureusement les accidents dits de
vacances noyade mais aussi des accidents
de monte ainsi ce matin une avalanche
vient de se produire dans le massif du
mont-blanc il semble qu'il n'y a pas de
victimes il y aurait six blessés par
ailleurs une corde et vient de dévisser
en haute savoie dans le massif de traits
la tête il y aurait trois morts et un
blessé grave et à l'instant j'apprends
que deux personnes ont trouvé la mort
dans le massif du pev des personnes
originaires des puits ricard le procès
se poursuit à aix en provence après
l'interruption d'audience d'hier matin
la cour a siégé jusqu'à 23h est
aujourd'hui le dernier témoin doit faire
ce matin aussi sa déposition et on pense
que le verdict sera rendu de toute façon
très tard demain soir enfin de moins 10
ans dans la soirée on est très inquiets
depuis hier soir sur l'état de santé de
luis mariano
le chanteur vient d'être frappée d'une
hémorragie cérébrale il a été transporté
d'urgence à l'hôpital de la salpêtrière
à paris après avoir été transporté
depuis biarritz par avion sanitaire
l'état de santé du chanteur inquiétait
déjà son entourage depuis quelques mois
et il faudra à dents
maintenant plusieurs jours avant de
connaître avec précision l'état de santé
du mal
luis mariano devait reprendre demain
soir le son opérette donc la caravelle
d'or est malheureusement bien sûr il ne
pourra pas tenir ce rôle mais en lui
souhaitant une meilleure santé voici
quelques phrases de 7
m
meilleure santé donc à luis mariano
pour aborder maintenant une rubrique la
rubrique science et technique nous
allons nous rendre dans les environs de
brest au boulet de brest pour être
précis et c'est là que se trouve le
centre de recherche océanologique de
bretagne ce centre dépend du cnec saut
les mecs au derrière ce sigle un peu
barbare se cache le centre national pour
l'exploitation des océans
cet organisme qui a vous savez
spécialisée dans cette passionnante
recherche pour sur l'espace sous marins
et surtout pour la conquête des océans
jusqu'à maintenant les océanologues
france est travaillée par petites
équipes ce qui ne leur permettait pas
d'aborder certaines études de grande
ampleur aussi en 1961 et il était décidé
de créer un centre de recherche
océanologique le centre de recherche
océanologique de bretagne vient d'être
inaugurée en présence de monsieur
bernard là c'est le secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre du développement
industriel et scientifique ce sera un
centre polyvalent qui rassemblera toutes
les équipes de chercheurs de toutes les
disciplines sociologique
il disposera de trois navires qui
bénéficient des équipements les plus
modernes à bord du jean charcot le
principal d'entre eux monsieur yves
lapeyrie directeur général du centre
national pour l'exploitation des océans
nous explique quels sont les objectifs à
atteindre pour la première fois
grande base sérologique française nous
aurons concentrer tous les moyens
modernes possible c'est pour ça il
fallait que ce soit l'état qui prennent
en charge tout le monde était d'accord
là dessus
alors à partir de là vous avez raison de
demander qu'est ce qu'il en sortira
alors c'est tout laventure du pétrole
pour lesquelles les travaux que nous
faisons permettent d'indiquer aux
compagnies pétrolières quels sont les
endroits les bons endroits dans le monde
entier
il faut se placer dès maintenant il ya
tout le domaine des minerais et ça c'est
un domaine qui est en pleine expansion
depuis seulement un an ou deux et là
aussi sans des places qui sont à prendre
très vite et que l'or il ya tout le
domaine de l'élevage marin l'agriculture
l'aquaculture et là il ya des pays qui
ont démarré très fort je crois qu'une
faut pas que nous soyons en retard et là
aussi je crois que les installations
si nous réussissons aussi bien qu'au
japon et après tout pourquoi pas
les installations sont rentabilisé en
quelques années parce que une fois
trouver les astuces scientifique et
technique bien le seuil économique est
assez rapidement atteint et puis ça va
être aussi ce centre d'informatique
océanologie dont nous voudrions bien au
franc qui deviennent le centre européen
je vous parlais des accidents de
vacances ou si bien la montagne à la mer
et bien je viens de recevoir un instant
une dépêche
disons que des recherches sont
actuellement entreprises pour retrouver
un yacht de 11 mètres 25 le mari grillon
à bord duquel se trouve monsieur félix
dr kane ancien président du conseil et
qui était seul à bord il était parti de
binic dans les côtes du nord pour se
rendre à jersey qu'il a quitté hier dans
la journée
ils devraient ils devaient très tôt
entre on l'attendait en tout cas hier
soir à 10h30 à binic et pour l'instant
l'hélicoptère de la protection civile de
granville effectué des recherches les
problèmes de vacances les problèmes de
circulation vous allez malheureusement
peut-être les connaître vous savez qu'en
france on a mis un dispositif très
important sur les routes mais je crois
que à l'étranger également ce problème
lui aussi a son importance et qu'on y
trouve quelques fois des solutions
vision assez original original que la
porte est une solution féminine
exactement
eh bien c'est exactement le cas au
canada où une jeune femme parcourt en
hélicoptère et survol en hélicoptère
plus exactement les autoroutes et les
grands axes routiers et indique par
radio quels sont les endroits à éviter
et aux contrats quelles sont les routes
après la sortie des bureaux
les quatre autoroutes principales de la
ville sur les bords du lac ontario sont
régulièrement bloqués
nous n'avons pas l'exclusivité des sans
doute énergie
dini petty connaît elle aussi ses
problèmes de circulation avant de se
rendre à son travail
deux fois par jour matin et soir sept
jours sur sept
combinaison de vol rose hélicoptère
boudoir rose elle est la voix de
l'oiseau rose pour une station de radio
de langue anglaise de toronto ces deux
pink lady amis de tous les
automobilistes coincés chaque matin
chaque soir aux portes de la ville
est-ce qu'il ya beaucoup de femmes au
canada qui pilote les hélicoptères comme
celui ci et qui travaille en gré d'un an
je suis une semaine seulement personne
qui qui volait le capteur wii
adam le mans il y à 138 138 femmes dans
une ha il y a dix femmes qui annonce
mais elles n'ont volé par tous les temps
hiver comme été toujours de rousse vêtue
au dessus des nuages de fumée la
pollution que l'on prévoit comme le
temps où la météo d'un jour sur l'autre
dini est au service de ceux qui
cherchent à rentrer ou sortir d'une
ville qui ingurgitent ou libère selon
les heures des centaines de milliers de
voitures après quatre heures de vol
quand tout est rentré dans l'ordre le
soir dîner se pose
elle sait ce métier depuis deux ans
aujourd'hui elle envisage de s'arrêter
pour désormais mener une vie moins
trépidante et plus féminine qu'est ce
que vous allez faire après avoir espéré
avec des enfants peter mais avoir des
enfants mais vous pouvez regarder un
sens et piloter un hélicoptère s'est pas
incompatible un non non j'ai je vais
aller les enfants en de spy faut
maintenant voir un sujet de mode des
robes des ensembles et des maillots de
bain une mode de vacances
un reportage de islami des images de
jean-louis saporito une mode pour vivre
décontractée loin des villes légère dans
la valise pas fragile cette mode offre
des maillots
des pantalons
voyez
ouais
mais
les robes de campagne
les manteaux de plage
des ceintures des colliers de chien des
bracelets de perles à n'en plus finir
ensemble de plage roumain de toile
blanche brodée de fleurs
combinaison en jersey chine et bleu et
blanc
le manteau de plage s'allonge et le
maillot se miniaturise avec soutien
gorge de rappeler
en masculins viennent la tunique et le
pantalon bouffant pour soi
c'est noir de bain en velours éponge
robe de campagne en toile et tricot et
cruel
m
ensemble de terrasses le maïeur de
danseuses à manches bouffantes et sa
jupes en jersey synthétique
draps de bain en tissu éponge imprimés
le mini maillot se cache sous une longue
jupe à ça ce voile sous une jupe de
mousseline
et
ensemble jeans jupes longues et boléro
sur tee-shirt de coton écoles
robes tablier en satin de coton imprimé
marineros paulo et maxi jupes en laine
chinée marine et blanc pour les vacances
à la mer ou à la campagne
la bourse de paris maintenant à vous
jean-michel 4 points et bien la bourse
de paris termine la semaine sur une note
plus optimiste et finalement les pertes
de lundi et mardi on était plus qu est
passé il faut dire que depuis deux jours
les bonnes nouvelles pour les boursiers
sont plus nombreuses que les mauvaises
ainsi ils ont accueilli avec
satisfaction l'accord signé hier entre
le patronat et les syndicats sur la
formation professionnelle de même
l'issue positive des négociations à la
ratp et la fin des grèves à orly ont
détendu l'atmosphère mais commis hier le
principal motif de satisfaction est
venue d'outre-atlantique wall street où
les investisseurs institutionnels ont
fait une réapparition en force a encore
gagné 10 points et vous savez quand wall
street se porte mieux paris oublie ses
soucis mais il est un autre sujet de
conversation aujourd'hui à la bourse de
paris
c'est celui de la réforme du système
monétaire international
cette réforme on en parle depuis
plusieurs années et c'est un peu comme
le serpent de mer on en parle beaucoup
mais on ne vous l'a voit pas venir
pourtant depuis les remous de ces
dernières années elle apparaît de plus
en plus nécessaire mercredi les experts
du club des 10 c'est à dire les 10 pays
les plus riches du monde se sont réunis
à paris
ils se sont penchés sur les projets
relatifs à une amélioration du
fonctionnement du système monétaire
international
depuis les accords de bretton-woods
signée en 1944 les parité des monnaies
sont fixes c'est à dire qu'elles ne
peuvent pas varié au jour le jour
une dévaluation ou une réévaluation est
un acte politique mais qui n'a pour but
en définitive que de refixer de refuge
est en quelque sorte la monnaie d'un
pays par rapport aux hommes or on parle
beaucoup depuis quelques temps de la
possibilité de laisser flotter les
bonnets leur parité évoluerait en
fonction de l'offre et de la demande de
la confiance qu'elle inspire les experts
du groupe des dix noms prix bien sûr
aucune décision
il n'en avait d'ailleurs pas le pouvoir
mais il mais ils ont décidé de
poursuivre leurs travaux et ils ont
défini trois champs d'études possibles
le premier consisterait en une
augmentation des marges de fluctuation
des monnaies jusqu'à 2 ou 3%
actuellement la limite autorisée par les
accords de bretton-woods n'est que de 1%
la seconde étude qui sera menée porte
sur l'institution de parts
et glissante en clair cela veut dire que
les parité des monnaies pourrait changer
plus souvent mais dans de faibles
proportions de l'ordre de 2 à 3 pour ça
en agissant plus souvent on éviterait
ainsi les gros changements supérieure à
10% qui bouleverse le système monétaire
ainsi pour prendre un exemple la france
aurait pu dévaluer de 2% dès juin 1968
et puis encore de 2 à 3% quelques mois
plus tard peut-être aurait-on pu éviter
alors la dévaluation de douze ennemis
pour sans doute dernier enfin le
troisième champ d'étude pour les experts
des 10 concerne les taux de change
flottant on laisserait la monnaie d'un
pays faute et pendant une période
transitoire donc limitée dans le temps
ceci permettrait un pays soit de
défendre sa monnaie soin de fixer une
nouvelle parité plus facilement déjà
l'allemagne en octobre dernier et le
canada il ya quelques semaines ont
utilisé ce procédé
ceci bien que les règles du système
monétaire international ne les
autorisent pas ou du moins pas encore
voilà donc les trois directions vers
lesquels on va on semble s'orienter et
on aura plus de précisions lors de la
prochaine réunion des 10 qui doit se
tenir au mois de septembre à copenhague
les valeurs étrangères aujourd'hui la
bourse de paris sont en hausse comme les
valeurs françaises it et gagne 2 francs
le petit andy d'été a annoncé que sa
société devrait augmenter son bénéfice
pour l'année 1970 nous allons passer sur
le marché de l'or où ce marché de l'or
il ya une tension on le lingot gagne 20
france est à relier avec les
perspectives de changement dans le
système monétaire international
la pièce sans cesse de 20 francs par
contre reste pratiquement inchangé les
autres pièces peu d'écart sur l'emprunt
pinay le 3 et demi pour cent ont côté ya
158 40 est aujourd'hui à l'ouverture 158
30 158,20 derrière donc 20 centimes de
pain la bourse va maintenant prendre des
petites vacances elle fera en effet le
pont pour le 14 juillet elle sera fermée
le lundi 13 et le mardi 14 et nous vous
donnons donc rendez vous
mao mercredi 15 juillet à vous jacques
est une annexe en télé midi et terminer
nos prochaines informations 18h50
messieurs vont se bonne journée partie